Sony's Dual Shock 4 for the ps4 is a
fine controller but what if you want
something that will give you an edge in
your games well I have to from scuf
gaming the impact and the infinity for
PS pro I put both through extensive
testing by playing titanfall 2 overwatch
blood-borne and horizon zero dawn to
find out if they're worth their hefty
price tag and they just might be if
you're looking for an advantage in
competitive or challenging games the
scuff impact starts at 140 dollars and
takes on a slightly larger body similar
to the Xbox one controller the audio
jack placement may make it difficult to
connect audio devices that have thick
casing or a 90-degree notch at the input
the scuff infinity for PS pro starting
at $130 is nearly identical to the Dual
Shock 4 in shape and size you can
customize their colorway and add
accessories on scuffs website but it'll
cost you a little bit more both have
modular designs the analog sticks can be
swapped out for ones that are either
concave convex or ones that protrude out
further but they are sold separately it
might be a little scary to pull them out
but a little force will work the analog
sticks themselves feel much smoother and
less resistant to move around in the
DualShock for both come packaged with
swappable l2 and r2 trigger extensions
which we used almost exclusively since
the extra surface area may trigger poles
bit easier the controller's featured
grippy surfaces on the handles and thumb
sticks which is one clear advantage face
buttons l1 r1 and the d-pad on both felt
very similar to the Dual Shock for using
the tool package with both controllers
you can adjust the trigger stops behind
l2 and r2 if you prefer a shorter throw
underneath the l2 and r2 caps is a hair
trigger mechanism that will lighten the
resistance of a trigger pole these can
help with twitch reactions however the
most attractive feature is the
programmable paddles the impact features
four paddles and the 4ps pro has two
paddles both controllers paddles can
easily be mapped to act as any other
button using the electromagnetic key
with paddles you never have to take your
thumb off the right stick allowing you
to look and aim without obstruction take
note that the two inner paddles on the
impact are a bit tough to press so you
may not want to map timely actions to
them
overall the paddles felt a little stiff
so spamming them is hard but they do
feel solid and tactile now that we know
what these controllers have to offer
let's get into how they perform in games
in titanfall 2 you're constantly jumping
strafing and wall running it's fast
paced and quick movement means you best
keep your head on a swivel however that
can be difficult with the default
controls we're jumping as map to the X
button by using one of the paddles to
act as X changing direction while
jumping and connecting wall runs was
indisputably easier and extremely
beneficial we also never had to stop
moving the camera to reload the smoother
nimble analog sticks also improved
granular movements for precise aiming in
overwatch a game with unique character
ability sets at programmed the jump
action and ultimate ability to the
paddles bunny hopping while in a
firefight was very advantageous floating
with my jump Jets as fara while being
able to shoot or use my concussive blast
simultaneously gave me an upper hand I
could also launch a barrage without
having to take my thumb off the right
stick which also proved useful for
pulling off a dragon strike as Hanzo or
locking targets for high noon as McCree
overwatch does let you fully customise
your controls by not having to make any
compromises with other actions was
useful the features of these controllers
were a little less important in
blood-borne since a game relies more on
timing and battle tactics the camera
follows enemies that are locked on so
having the dodge action mapped to a face
button didn't hold us back from
surviving and taking down the creatures
of yharnam we did find it helpful to
have the consumable and items action
designated to a paddle in case we had to
dodge at a moment's notice
while horizon zero dawn isn't a
competitive shooter or as unforgiving as
blood-borne moving the camera and
simultaneously dodging in the heat of
battle was one gripe I had with the
game's controls now with a paddle acting
a circle I could dodge enemy attacks
while moving the camera a significant
advantage for
damage escaping or getting in a better
position both the scuff impact and
infinity for PS pro provide distinct
advantages over the DualShock for the
extra grip was handy especially for the
thumbsticks
and the smooth movement of those sticks
helped with precise aiming most
importantly the programmable paddles
were easy enough to use but extremely
beneficial in the games we played since
we never had to take our thumbs off of
sticks however if you don't feel the
need for these features then these
controllers may not make much of a
difference for you and since they're
both priced well over $100 you might
want to think twice about pulling the
trigger if you found this review
informative please give us a thumbs up
and subscribe to our channel here at
GameSpot and stay tuned for our review
of the Nikon revolution and Razer Ryu
ps4 controllers thanks for watching